[Religious opera]
⛪Christian PewDiePie here⛪
last week I asked you to send anything food related
Let's see how you guys did
You know, I flexed a little bit this week with my meatball cooking skills
and a lot of people were jealous
They were judging me they were hating on me
Oh, you can't oh, you can't use a metal spatula with a Teflon plate
shut the f*ck up
Oh you made vegetarian meatballs what are you f*cking [Christian poods theme] vegan?
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry
I enjoy the flavor of it a little bit more
literally bunch of crybabies
my god
Oh boy, I'm a chef and this made me cringe.
Oh, I'm sorry
I didn't dedicate my life to this very one thing
I bet you my meatballs tasted way savior (savoury) than yours
Way fresher than yours
way fatter, way lumpier,
way browner, way better than yours
Go home
Okay, now we've that we're done with that. Let's judge what you guys did with food last week all right
What am I looking at here?
That totally caught me off guard what what is this?
Oh I see it now this drawing is very nice,
very nice drawing
I put tomatoes in my cheeks, very nice.
And bananas in my hair, very nice
and chilis in my beard,
VERY NICE (( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
PewDiepie after YouTube
It's food-related so you get zero points
because it wasn't funny shut up. I don't look like that
I literally created a reddit just to submit this.
Original content
Whiskey tasting you laugh. You lose.
Well you forgot to add crafting videos and cooking videos. Thank you very much
Oh, that's not original content for you
literally
Cry more.
You're all a bunch of crybaby pussies
I bet you're sitting sucking on your mama's titties
What happened to me Christian Channel, Christian Channel goddamn Felix.
Gosh darn Felix.
*Blowing air*
Why do you have to annoy me so much?
Hey Marzia, I turned myself into a-
*chuckling*
*wheezing*
There's a damn big meatball
if that is Edgar for a scale reference.
Helvete. Christian chocolate.
Okay, all right
*Burps*
*laughs*
Now that looks good.
They're PewDie Puffs. Heck yeah man!
Heck yeah!
disrespecting wahmen
NO!
Zero deffs
heck Yeah
Salty Brad
all the way.
That is some fine Photoshop right there.
Papi pixel as always well done
Look Edgar. You want to eat those?
Huh? You want to eat those
That means he likes it.
What is up guys my name is PewDiePie.
How's it going bros? My name is PewDiePie.
What's up guys. It's your boy-
*laughs*
Well done. Okay. You made me, you made me chuckle well done. What do you want-
an award for chuckling? That's not a thing.
That's not a thing you can go now. Bye
*laughs*
Stop. What the heck?
Listen to this
See how they're bullying me Edgar?
Do something!
Did you post this?
Summary of PewDiePie.
This channel doesn't have any content.
Can we get one nice one? Can we just get one-
I'm sure there's one nice one in here.
Swedish meatballs with Irish potatoes.
It looks delicious
I'd eat that.
Want some noodles?
Listen here you f-
How do I say this? How do I emphasize
how stupid you are?
Stop calling spaghetti, noodles. Okay?
This is spaghetti
This is spaghetti.
This is noodles
learn the difference.
It's not that hard.
Asian - European
ASIAN! EUROPEAN!!
you racist cultural appropriating
Son-of-a-bitches
oh they want some noodles.
No. I want spaghetti
Spaghetti. I want spaghetti
Not noodles.
It's not that hard okay
I want to call you a bunch of fucking retards, but I can't cuz I'm a Christian Channel.
OHHHHH, WOAHOHHOHOHO,
My god, it's a parity banana.
You seeing this Edgar
that looks just like mehehe
This is fucking. This is sexy. This is hell heck yeah, man
This is some nice,
ooh
Very very
Excuse me while I zoom in on my face, and I say
oh. a, a very nice.
Oh my Lord and Savior PewDiePie I'm the Savior
*chuckling*
Gentlemen we can rebuild him we have the technology
Too-Too bad well done you win this one wins by default
EMD1594
My neighbor. You're my neighbor buddy.
When they tell you the private line will be finished within 47 days, but it's 2046
Jacksepticeye has reached 50 million subs Brad is finally not salty in PUBG
Elon Musk has been announced president of the first Mars country, and you still have shit Internet.
Can someone Please save me from my bad internet? It's not funny anymore.
I'm not even joking
I just want to die.
Whoa! Edgar-Maya cupcakes
with psychedelic slippy interior.
Oh, that's so cool
What I don't even see that. That's so dope
Edgar, look, you're a cupcake
You're a cupcake Edgar
Look Edgar, you're a cupcake.
What's that?
You're black not brown.
Oh my god. You're racist listen here listen here. We're gonna Have a talk later tonight
that is amazing. Thank you very much Gfroehrli .
I want to eat that. That looks good
I would eat Edgar if you know what I mean.
That was a weird joke. I don't know what-
PewDiePie after too much food
Oh my god. It does look like me what the heck.
Who is that man?
well,
It looks like I have a bright future ahead of me. Look at that man.
Stunningly beautiful.
Nice chair. Noob-Pro
You making fun of my chair.
You're making fun of my pristine
Beautiful gaming chair,
bet you can't even get laid
*laughing*
It's a RiceGum level insult.
A very nice food meme Mars-ia
*Clapping*
Wow you are so clever
well done
oh Look at those spa-Jeffy
whoa
I've seen this on Twitter.
It's so cool.
I don't know how it's done,
but naolocked, Thank you
I love how you guys accept the challenge man. It's so fun to see.
So cool.
I bet you it was delicious
I bet you it tastes as savory as my balls. Ah my meatballs.
The meatballs that I cooked in my video
Thank you very much
Is what I'm trying to say
Christian Channel.
When your channel Christian as f*ck and you're trying to make memes about food.
Eat and you shall never be demonetized
That's right.
I'm the savior from the apocalypse.
Eat my meatballs
You will be saved.
top 10 hottest anime muffins
Look at the thickness in my legs goddamn man.
Made me laugh so hard, Marzia is really enjoying
*laughing*
Remember Markiplier, Jacksepticeye and PewDiePie this is them now. Feel old yet?
That's funny well done
I have been waiting my whole life to submit this
It's beautiful
Carved a brofist into a nectarine. That's cool.
I didn't know you could do that
I didn't know you could carve in nectarines,
but that's cool. I bet that nectarine was savory as my-
Alright. *clapping*
Last page I've been really impressed this time. You know,
I wasn't- I'm not that disappointed.
What a nice PewDie-Pie
But where's the con-?
I don't need this.
I don't need this. I really don't.
You know I could just stop. I'm stopping
There's nowhere for me to go over there.
It's just a wall, but whatever.
You know what, I forgive you cuz I'm a Christian channel.
You're welcome.
Take PewDiePie, take food and smash them together.
No don't smash. No.
No you know what, that's just rude, man.
Why do you have a PewDiePie cut-
you know, never mind.
I made what I believe to be the dish that best Represents PewDiePie.
It took 10 minutes to make with low effort, tastes the same every time, and is pure whi-
Well, I'm sure it tastes great.
When you make a food challenge and look at the submissions and realize your fans are talentless losers
and now you're going to have to do another You Laugh You Lose because you're out of content ideas.
And then has to upload an edit the same You Laugh You Lose 4 times until it gets monetized.
I did seven times last time
Thank you very much,
and can't I get a little of bit of praise whatever.
I don't need this
I really don't need this.
What?! Brofist hard candy from when I was bored at work.
Wait how do you make this, and how do you make so many?
They look good. That looks amazing? That's awesome
well done candyprincess23
oh
my
Gah-hahahaha
F*cking spit
Christian channel
PewDiePie the Sims
Play horror, make 10:01, Leave BuzzFeed, complain on YouTube, yell
come on. I'm not, I'm not that obvious
Okay, you never know what you're gonna get. that's the point of the PewDiePie channel,
you never know what you gonna get.
You're welcome .
now I'm not like all these mainstream channels doing the same content over and over
and over and over and over.
Okay, I'll keep you guys on your toes. I keep you guessing.
I bet you didn't know this video was gonna come up. hmm
I bet you didn't know Christian Channel was gonna take off.
That's right. All right. It's time to end it here
It was a good show. You hit all the marks unoriginal content and more unoriginal content.
I get it okay
I get it. My hair, making fun of my appearance
Oh you think I'm so insecure
oh
If there was a modeling contest I bet you I would win it.
And if there was an IQ Contest I bet you, I'm Rick and Morty and you're Dora the Explorer.
Okay, so next time you talk shiz
You know what next time talk shiz
Bring it okay. Next time. I want you to roast me.
and then post a picture of yourself
because then I will roast you back if you dare.
if you even dare
Consensually
If you're over 18
and Marzia allows it.
Oh, that's what I'm gonna Do okay,
so post a f*cking picture see who's a tough guy huh.
See who's a tough guy, maybe like if you enjoyed this video?
Thank you guys so much for watching. I love you guys so much
squad fam  *ka chicka*